[Music]
foreign
to year in review the show where we
break down a year to bring you some of
the most notable moments in TV and film
month by month let's take things back to
the beginning of a decade and not just
any decade we're talking about the 90s
that's right 1990 when the 80s were
fresh in the rear view and 10 more years
of highs and lows awaited cheers was
dominating the airwaves in its ninth
season while a couple of guys named
Brandon and Dylan were about to teach a
new generation all about sideburns movie
stars like Bruce Willis and Arnold
Schwarzenegger continued to shine while
future stars like Julia Roberts were
coming in hot plus a new Christmas
classic was about to be born so get
ready to do some voguing thanks to a
popular Madonna song that year because
this is gonna be fun 1990 here we come
[Music]
my husband told me to run a car yes I
remember everything he said so don't you
think even for a second that you better
wait your your speeding I can see it no
almost there isn't home we're only doing
about 19 miles an hour I like to go
under the speed limit yeah awesome but
speed limit is 35 yeah and helping kick
the 90s off at a leisurely Pace was the
film Driving Miss Daisy Jessica Tandy
stars as an elderly woman living in
Atlanta who against her wishes takes on
a chauffeur played by Morgan Freeman to
help her get around town and while
things are Rocky at first they
eventually form a close friendship
[Music]
I have to tell you about the first time
I leave the state of Georgia
few minutes back
but it was Tandy who was really driving
the hype train as her Oscar win for best
actress was one of four the film earned
not to mention best picture out of nine
nominations critics say while it's
fueled in part by outdated stereotypes
Driving Miss Daisy takes audiences on a
heartwarming Journey with a pair of
outstanding actors
[Music]
I'm sure you'll understand I'm not
thrilled with the idea of your turning
40 Years of my work into your garage
sale at the price I'm paying for this
stock Mr Morris you are going to be a
very rich man I'm rich enough I just
want to head by Shipyard
foreign
and walking down the street and into
theaters in March of 1990 was the hit
rom-com pretty woman Julia Roberts stars
in this film as Vivian Ward a
free-spirited Hollywood sex worker who
has hired for a week by a businessman
named Edward played by Richard Gere
initially the film was pitched as a dark
drama about prostitution in Los Angeles
in the 1980s including themes like
Vivian being a drug addict thankfully it
was Jeffrey katzenberg president of Walt
Disney Studios at the time who insisted
that the film instead be a modern day
love story
hmm something's missing
well nothing else is going to fit into
this draft I'll tell you that maybe
something in this box
I don't want you to get too excited it's
only on alone
Pretty Woman pulled in over 460 million
dollars worldwide to become the third
highest grossing film of 1990 and for
her efforts Roberts received a Golden
Globe award for her performance and was
also nominated for a Best Actress Oscar
but lost to Kathy Bates for misery more
importantly however is that she
solidified her seat at the big star
table critics say pretty woman may be a
yuppie fantasy but the film's Slick
comedy soundtrack and casting can
overcome misgivings
you fight well
in the old style
but you've caused me enough trouble
now you face
the shredder
the shredder uh maybe all that Hardware
is for making coleslaw and from the
sewers to the theaters in March came
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles directed by
Steve Barron who is probably best known
for directing Michael Jackson's Billie
Jean music video
damn I'm good this film follows four
turtles who are mutated by radioactive
ooze and went on to become crime
fighting ninjas hey it happens with the
one and only Corey Feldman providing the
voice of Donatello he's the brains of
the operation this movie was an
adaptation of the early TMNT comics and
borrowed a few more elements from the
popular animated series at the time and
if you haven't had enough fun facts for
this one just know that the turtle
costumes were developed by Jim Henson's
Creature Shop one of the last projects
before Henson's death the more you know
yes friends the new turbo Ginsu
whoops
kids Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles was a
box office success and set the stage for
two early 90s sequels before a total
reboot in 2014. Cowabunga critics say
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is exactly
as advertised one-liners brawls and
general silliness good for the young at
heart irritating for everyone else
[Music]
and arriving a few decades early or was
it late in May of 1990 was Back to the
Future Part three the final installment
of the Back to the Future Trilogy with
director Robert zemeckis and the main
cast once again returning this time
Marty McFly finds out about the death of
his buddy Doc Brown in 1985 and must
travel back in time to save him leading
to them trying to figure out how to
escape the dangers of the old west and
get themselves wait for it
Back to the Future
foreign
[Music]
with a 40 million dollar budget filming
began shortly after Back to the Future
Part 2 wrapped and took place partially
in Arizona where the production team
built the 1885 Hill Valley set from
scratch rather than using existing sets
part 3 opened just six months after the
previous installment and grossed 246
million dollars worldwide to become the
sixth highest grossing film of the Year
critics say Back to the Future Part 3
draws the trilogy to a satisfying close
with a simpler sweeter round of time
travel antics
foreign
[Music]
released on June 1st was the Arnold
Schwarzenegger action flick Total Recall
directed by Paul Vero Hoven and based on
the 1966 short by Philip K dick in it
Arnold Schwarzenegger stars as a
futuristic man whose life gets
dangerously confusing after he has
virtual vacation memories of visiting
Mars planted in his head the movie was
shot almost entirely in sequence and
used a lot of practical special effects
amounting to a reported budget of
between 50 and 80 million dollars which
was huge for the time
this
[Music]
Total Recall ultimately had Solid box
office success and despite mixed reviews
upon its release the now certified fresh
film is viewed by many as one of
Schwarzenegger's best projects and in
the years since the movie has gone full
franchise with comic books video games a
TV adaptation and a film remake critics
say under Paul verhoven's frenetic
Direction Total Recall is a fast-paced
rush of violence Gore and humor that
never slacks
thank you
hey
that's a restricted area what's the
matter could wait for the sky cap we
work here
let's see some IDs
[Music]
and bringing snow-covered action to 4th
of July weekend in 1990 was Die Hard 2.
the second installment in the Die Hard
film series if you couldn't tell by the
number two part of it this one takes
place a year after Bruce Willis's John
McClane saved nakatomi Plaza in Los
Angeles this time finding himself
battling Terror threats at a Washington
DC airport jeez the luck with this guy
John McClain yeah yeah I know who you
are you're the [__] that just broke
seven FAA and five District of Columbia
regulations run around my airport with a
gun shooting at people what do you call
that
self-defense
while the first Die Hard was based on a
1979 Roderick Thorpe novel this
installment was adapted from Walter
wagger's 1987 novel called 58 minutes
but with a few plot points and names
changed to match the franchise the
result was a bigger box office return
that nearly doubled the first one and an
overall strong reception from fans and
critics so why not do it again and again
and again you get the point critics say
it lacks the fresh Thrills of its
predecessor But Die Hard 2 still works
as an over-the-top and reasonably taught
big budget sequel with plenty of set
pieces to paper over the plot
deficiencies I need you to tell Molly
what I'm saying but you have to tell her
word for word all right word for word
yes he wants me to tell you what he's
saying word for word
Molly you're in danger now you can't
just blurt it out like that and quit
moving around where you could start to
make me dizzy I just tell her in my own
way and also making itself seen in July
was the film ghost marking the first
time the director Jerry Zucker worked
solo after co-directing comedies like
airplane and Top Secret the movie stars
Patrick Swayze as a murdered man who
tracks down a psychic played by Whoopi
Goldberg to help him protect his
girlfriend from the person who killed
him even with its impressive cast which
also included Demi Moore in a starring
role this film somewhat exceeded
expectations
it grossed 505 million dollars at the
worldwide box office to become the
highest grossing film of 1990 and the
third highest grossing film ever at the
time ghost was also nominated for five
Academy Awards including best picture
and won two for best original screenplay
and best supporting actress for Goldberg
and let's be honest it gave us a certain
pottery wheel scene that would be
spoofed and parodied for years to come
critics say ghost offers viewers a
poignant romance while blending elements
of comedy horror and mystery all adding
up to one of the most enduringly
watchable hits of its era
[Music]
are you telling me McDaniel was not a
random victim all right we got a
specialist who says the only way this
thing makes sense is that the recipient
had a condition that required a match
and McDaniel's kidney fits the bill well
he'd have to be tested to make sure but
the problem is McDaniel swears from that
on Sunday that he's never been tested
Grand Theft kidney terrific and just
when 1990 needed a little law in order
to help set things straight in came the
new drama series Law and Order in
September hey not every intro can be a
winner okay cut us some slack created by
Dick Wolf who would use this show to
become a Powerhouse in the industry Law
and Order regularly uses the formula of
following a crime usually murder during
the investigation and then the court
prosecution over the course of an hour
Biko wants to deal you're the barter big
Los altar out on bail don't you think
it's funny nobody came forward to help
you big fish eat little or fish I had
nothing to do with it legal result to
tell a different story you know the
truth Joe
you don't know what you're asking me was
it rueful
the series initially ended in 2010 after
20 seasons and was revived in 2022. the
emmy-winning show spawned a franchise
that includes video games a TV movie
International adaptations and more
series including Law and Order SVU which
is now the longest running live-action
scripted show ever critics say formulaic
to be sure law order nonetheless
synthesizes an endlessly watchable blend
of crime procedural Intrigue and legal
system Dramatics what do you mean funny
funny how how am I funny
I'm not just
you know how you tell a story what
no no I don't know you said it how do I
know you said I'm funny how the [__] am
I funny what the [__] is so funny about
me tell me tell me what's funny
get the [__] out of here to tell me
and the same month Law and Order came to
TV 1990 organized crime hit theaters in
the form of Goodfellas directed and
co-written by Martin Scorsese based on
the 1985 book wiseguide by Nicholas
palegi who co-wrote the screenplay with
Scorsese this film Chronicles the rise
and fall of mob associate Henry Hill
played by Ray Liotta from 1955 to 1980.
for most of the guys killing's got to be
accepted murder was the only way that
everybody stayed in line you got out of
line you got whacked everybody knew the
rules with a cast that also includes
Robert De Niro Joe Pesci Goodfellas was
nominated for six Oscars including best
picture and Best Director with Pesci
winning for best supporting actor and as
our own United States Library of
Congress recognized it with entry into
the national film registry this movie
has been regarded as one of the best
films ever made especially in the
gangster genre critics say hard-hitting
and stylish Goodfellas is a gangster
classic and arguably the high point of
Martin scorsese's career
[Music]
what's Beverly isn't like other schools
kids here are richer some of their
parents are celebs so it's definitely
not your normal high school especially
it's really intense you make one false
move in your history I mean if people
here saw you eating lunch alone today
like that guy over there
you know I had a lot of great friends at
my old school this show followed a group
of friends living in Beverly Hills
California depicting their journey
through High School into college and
Beyond and while it did touch on some
serious topics at times 90210 also had
plenty of teen drama and romance
Marianne
oh liar
can you do that how can you go around
spreading those rumors after I spilled
my guts to you like that hey I had
nothing to do with it I swear you know
you just like
get a name for yourself
I didn't say anything well then who did
the show ran for 10 seasons on Fox but
ended up being just the first of six
series and the 90210 franchise and while
the cast and Fashions evolved over time
the iconic sideburns worn by Jason
priestley's character when the show
first kicked off are hard to ignore and
should never be forgotten
[Music]
yeah
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more
[Music]
ah
and not to be forgotten in November of
1990 was the theatrical release of Home
Alone directed by Chris Columbus a
couple of years after making his debut
with Adventures in Babysitting Macaulay
Culkin stars in this film about a boy
who has accidentally left behind when
his family heads to the airport in a
hurry leaving him with a big empty house
and two burglars who have been causing
chaos in the neighborhood Home Alone was
written by John Hughes who also wrote
another holiday classic in National
Lampoon's Christmas Vacation the year
before Oh
shut it Mom
please
hey guys
check this out
go back
Hughes who conceived the film while
preparing for vacation and wondering
what would happen if he left his son
behind suggested that they cast Culkin
after his experience with the actor on
Uncle Buck the movie grossed nearly 477
million dollars worldwide to become the
highest grossing live-action comedy
until The Hangover Part 2 in 2011. plus
it made Culkin a child star on the way
to becoming an absolute must-watch flick
every December critics say home alone's
uneven but frequently funny premise
stretched unreasonably thin is buoyed by
Macaulay Culkin's Q performance and
strong supporting Stars
issue
it has no nobility
not
you think I say when I go to the feed
store in town oh now Wally give me a bag
of that effing pig feed and 10 pounds
that cow corn and bringing a little Joy
to the fall weather in November of 1990
was the Stephen King adaptation misery
directed by Rob Reiner and based on
King's 1987 novel of the same name the
film stars Kathy Bates as the obsessive
fan of an author played by James Khan
who holds him captive in her house and
forces him to rewrite the finale of his
famous book series
have the power
to give misery
eternal life
we must finish the book
but the time is now
soon others will come
[Music]
the little-known baits ended up with the
roll after names like Bette Midler and
Angelica Houston turned it down and she
made the most of it earning plenty of
critical praise to go along with a Best
Actress Oscar still the only Stephen
King adaptation with an Academy Award
critics say elevated by standout
performances from James Khan and Kathy
Bates this taught and frightening film
is one of the best Stephen King
adaptations to date
[Music]
to make it a five run inning and slow
this game to Pieces I'll be done
and closing out 1990 by keeping things
on The Cutting Edge was the film Edward
Scissorhands released on December 14th
Johnny Depp stars in the film as a
mysterious young man with scissor blades
for hands who comes to live with a kind
woman and her family including a
daughter played by Winona Ryder and ends
up disrupting their Community with his
odd but Charming ways the film was
directed by Tim Burton who conceived it
from his childhood upbringing in
Suburban Burbank California with the
Genesis of Edward coming from a drawing
he did as a teenager and the film got
fast-tracked thanks to Burton's critical
and financial success with 1989's Batman
foreign
[Music]
Burton brought in Big Time Pros like
composer Danny eltman for music and the
legendary Stan Winston to create the
Scissorhands and it's the first time
Burton collaborated with Johnny Depp
which must have been a good time because
they would become friends and go on to
make many many more films together
critics say the first collaboration
between Johnny Depp and Tim Burton
Edward Scissorhands is a magical modern
fairy tale with Gothic overtones and a
sweet Center well there it is 1990
tightly rolled into one nice fancy
package if we learned one thing today
it's that no matter if you were alive or
not in 1990 there's no better time than
right now to relive that magical year
and there's no better way to do it than
with movies and shows like these and
also sideburns thanks for checking out
our urine review for 1990 we'll see you
next time